notre invité politique ce matin c'est
damien abad merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous bonjour député de l'ain président
du groupe l'est républicain à
l'assemblée nationale on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
et de ouest france stéphane bonjour
bonjour on va évidemment parler de
l'actualité nationale mais d'abord un
mot sur l'actualité internationale avec
vous damien abad nouvelle escalade de
tension hier entre la france et le mali
la junte malienne a ordonné à
l'ambassadeur français de quitter le
pays sous les 72 heures les autorités
maliennes qui justifie cette décision
par les déclarations hostiles de
responsables français à leur rencontre
la france elle a réagi via le quai
d'orsay elle a déclaré prendre note dont
acte d'abord c'est une humiliation
ultime pour la france je pense à tous
ces soldats français qui sont morts au
mali à toutes ces familles de soldats
qui sont à côté engagé pour tout
simplement défendre et bien la france et
je trouve cette humiliation non
seulement regrettable mais inacceptable
et la réalité aujourd'hui c'est qu'après
le départ du danemark après le départ la
suède on voit bien aujourd'hui
l'isolément de la france et que cette
situation qui n'est pas tenable à court
terme qu'il faut quitter le manier que
l'opération barca ne peut plus rester la
bataille savez moi je suis de ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut lutter contre le
terrorisme partout mais la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que la question doit
être posée parce qu'on peut pas
continuer avec ces humiliations
permanentes à voir des soldats qui
meurent au mali et dans le même temps
des putschistes qui renvoie notre
ambassadeur c'est une situation qui
n'est pas acceptable il faut faire autre
chose que prendre note aussi à ce que la
foule va
réagir beaucoup de beaucoup ferment la
france et l'europe pas continuer cette
humiliation là en afrique et on le voit
un moment où il ya dans le même temps
une crise entre l'ukraine et la russie
ont bien de ce mouvement de tension
géopolitique majeur donc oui il faut une
réaction forte quelle est la position de
valérie pécresse sur ce sur ce sujet à
écouter valérie pécresse elle dit très
clairement qu'aujourd'hui la question de
se pose du maintien de nos soldats
français que les y est favorable oui
mais y'en a toujours été favorable sur
le principe parce que nous considérons
que c'est le devoir et la responsabilité
la france mais la france ne pas être
seul pas être isolé nous sommes en plein
résidence de l'union européenne est en
plein de présidence de l'union
européenne dirigée par la france nous
avons danemark la suède et non deux
alliés qui quitte finalement le
territoire vous parlez de la russie l
ukraine où là aussi les tensions sont
vives la france qui pour envoyer des
soldats à la frontière ukrainienne dans
le cadre de l'otan est ce que pour vous
le parlement doit avoir son mot à dire
est ce que vous demandez à un débat sur
ces sujets de toute façon normalement
quand on engage non forces armées on a
un débat au parlement qui est nécessaire
indispensable bien entendu voilà là
aussi on a une situation de tension qui
est extrêmement forte et enseignants
pointent dans les prochains jours je
souhaite qu'on ait un débat au parlement
bien sûr pour engager nos forces parce
que c'est important c'est la
représentation nationale et que donc
c'est dans tout pays démocratique on
doit pouvoir le faire
brigitte bourguignon reçoit aujourd'hui
le directeur d'orpea le groupe de
maisons de retraite soupçonné de
maltraitance dans un livre qui vient de
livres enquêtes qui vient de sortir
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que peut faire
qu'est ce que peut faire qu'est ce que
doit faire l'état sur ce sujet
d'abord cette situation là n'est pas
acceptable peut pas faire du fric sur la
dignité des personnes âgées l'état doit
faire plusieurs choses d'abord un
meilleur contrôle une meilleure
évaluation de ses gestionnaires privés
dans les ehpad ça veut dire c'est ce que
nous avons proposé à valérie pécresse et
philippe juvin c'est d'avoir une
évaluation un cadre avec des indicateurs
de performance très concrètement ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire savoir combien
comme une fois en douche les personnes
les résidents qui sont en ehpad est ce
qu'on prend suffisamment de temps pour
les nourrir on sait que par exemple les
malades alzheimer dégustation et de la
déglutition et plus compliqué donc il ya
un certain nombre d'indicateurs et les
contrôles aujourd'hui soit insuffisant
vous pensez bien sûr mais le fait bien
sûr mais après on va se parler
franchement faut pas croire que dans les
ehpad publics la situation est reluisant
c'est différent parce qu'il ya pas de
but lucratif mais la réalité c'est
qu'ils manquent aussi de moyens humains
aussi de personnel et qui a
malheureusement aussi beaucoup de
souffrance au travail la faute à qui
vous avez été président de département
vous d'amiens des skis à une défaillance
aussi des collectivités locales ont
croisé les départements aujourd'hui ils
ont plus les moyens de faire cela moi
j'ai été prise en département j'ai
relevé le direct au directeur quand je
suis arrivé les taux directeurs c'est à
dire en fait ce que l'on vote pour les
ehpad pour les maisons de retraite
chaque année je les relevés de 1% ce
avaient été gelées sous la mandature
précédente par la gauche et pendant
trois ans pourquoi on a fait ça pour
augmenter les moyens mais la vérité
c'est que département n'ont pas les
moyens de cette politique et c'est la
deuxième chose que doit faire l'êta
c'est à dire des états généraux de la
dépendance une réforme de la dépendance
et du grand âge parce qu'aujourd'hui il
ya un besoin criant de financement et il
faut tout repenser du sol au plafond ça
ça je pense l'une des grandes réformes
du prochain quinquennat c'est un enjeu
c'est son jour est ce que dans les cent
jours est derrière cette réforme de la
dépendance très clairement oui oui
pourquoi parce que elle prendra 50 cette
réforme c'est une réforme de long terme
je lesquels il faut tout revoir parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce à un coût extrêmement
important pour l'état pour les finances
publiques mais cinq ou six pour les
familles qui est extrêmement important
et on n'a pas un autre millier de retour
sur résultats mais moi je n'oublie pas
ce qui s'est passé pendant la crise
sanitaire pendant la crise sanitaire le
droit de visite des familles qui étaient
interdits dans un moment quand même
compliquée pendant la première vague et
puis les portes de réanimation qui était
fermé pour certains résidents des ehpad
donc les ehpad ce ne sont ni en prison
ni un mouroir il ya l'enjeu de la
médicalisation des ehpad qu'elle ait pas
de nous voulons demain et surtout
comment on construit l'ehpad hors les
murs et au delà des pad comment
renforcer service des aides à domicile
et ce qui a été fait au cours du
quinquennat quinqua vous paraît
complètement un gars ils ont été faits
alors bye quand même lui des
investissements une part d du ségur de
la santé il ya eu des investissements
pour les les établissements il ya eu le
cinquième pilier la sécurité sociale des
avancées aussi sur les salaires les
aides soignants le dispositif sur les
accompagnements familiaux il ya comme
une idée chose de faite je veux dire
deux choses d'abord la veille le produit
sur la santé c'est qu'il est centre
hospitalo centre et ça veut dire quoi ce
à dire qu'en gros il est concentré sur
l'hôpital les services d'aidé à domicile
tout ce qui tourne autour médico social
n'est pas considéré quand même un volet
investissement dans les échanges sur
l'immobilier sur les personnes oui mais
ça ne suit ça fait partie du problème ça
ne suffit pas et la réalité surtout
c'est qu'on a voté le principe dans le
financement dans la loi mais aucune
application concrète est donc
aujourd'hui la question de la cinquième
branche période se pose moi j'ai une
question commence où est passé l'argent
qu'on avait qu'on avait promis pour les
personnes âgées dans le cadre du lundi
de pentecôte et d'essence et financé
justement
sa dépendance l'a donc aujourd'hui une
question de financement même pas
seulement une question d'organisation
savoir qui fait quoi quel est le degré
de compétence des départements qu'elle
ne devait être communiqué aux deux
compétences de l'état là dedans bref
c'est une réforme au long cours qu'il
faut faire et qu'il faut engager en
début de ce quinquennat clairement
puisque brigitte bourguignon annonce ce
matin lançait deux enquêtes dont une de
l'inspection générale des finances est
ce que c'est suffisant pour nom mais ces
enquêtes internes sont nécessaires bien
entendu après moi je suis n'est pas la
petite l'objectif n'est pas de jeter le
pilori sur au rhdp en particulier la
vérité c'est qu'il ya certainement
d'autres groupes privés là il ya une
enquête parce que le livre a été
concentrée sur un pea mais ça aurait pu
être un autre groupe je le dis aussi ça
aurait pu être sur certains ehpad
publics donc je pense qu'il faut pas le
si on se trouve si on pense que seule
une enquête sur orpea suffira non il ya
bien un opéra doit bien sûr rendez
compte il ya des dysfonctionnements
manifestes c'est très clair mais au-delà
de ça il faut faire plusieurs choses et
nous ce que nous proposons par exemple
c'est lorsque on aura mis en place des
indicateurs de résultats que les ehpad
qui ne respecteront pas les
établissements qui ne respecteraient pas
ça il faut les fermer qu'ils soient
privés comme publics il faut pour les
femmes quant à ceux qui disent il faut
tout nationaliser mais c'est une vaste
blague parce que la réalité ça coûterait
plus de 15 milliards d'euros je préfère
cet argent là il se fait à la réforme de
la dépendance et du grand âge on va
parler des policiers puisque gérald
darmanin annoncé qu'il allait recevoir
les syndicats de policiers vendredi déjà
plus de dix policiers se sont suicidés
depuis le 1er janvier comment on répond
à ce malaise d'abord ça veut dire qu'il
ya un policier qui se suicident tous les
deux jours et demi depuis le début de
l'année ce qui est terrible c'est un
effroi on y répond d'abord par une
donner du sens à la fonction de policier
aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup de
troubles de traumatisme post traumatique
son impasse hier après des événements
qui se sont passés qui sont extrêmement
douloureux des policiers qui sont
souvent livrés à eux mêmes qui en plus
ont été parfois pas défendu je parle pas
de monsieur darmanin mais par le passé
pas défendue par le maître des ministres
l'intérieur précédent en plus de ça on
sait clairement il défend et et ensuite
au delà de ça il ya aussi un problème de
la fonction c'est que l'absence de
réponse pénale fait que gagne lassitude
très forte des policiers qui ont le
sentiment à chaque fois de vivre des
épreuves physiques très dur ils ont
passé le lycée devenus les casques bleus
au cirque en fait on a le droit d'être
retirés de suisse n'ont pas droit de se
défendre c'est ça la réalité jour de la
police en france donc un problème de
sens c'est extrêmement grave parce que
si ce qui nous protège dont sept dans
une telle situation d'affaiblissement
moral et psychologique ça nous montre
l'état de la société française donc il
faut les défendre il faut faire de la
prévention bien entendu il ya des choses
sic aux logiques à mettre en place mais
pas seulement c'est aussi leur donner
les moyens directs de leurs actions vous
évoquez la réponse pénale c'est à dire
que pour vous il ya clairement aussi une
partie du problème qui vient de la
justice là c'est pareil sur le
quinquennat vous estimez que les
réformes qui ont été mises en place ont
sont où les moyens supplémentaires
donnés sont notoirement insuffisants je
considère que la réforme de la justice
la réforme pénale sont les angles morts
du quinquennat d' emmanuel macron c'est
à dire parce que c'est à dire qu'en fait
on a fait le boulot de la sécurité mais
on a oublié de mettre dedans la réforme
pénale et très concrètement ça veut dire
quoi rien sur les peines planchers rien
sur la meilleure exécution des peines
rien sur la construction des places de
prison on voit bien qu on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui la limite ça s'est arrêté
à beauvau et que donc à partir de là on
n'a rien changé et là il c'est un
chantier énorme que la droite
républicaine doit se saisir non pas en
faisant des slogans des effets de manche
comme madame le pen monsieur zemmour
veulent faire pour agiter les passions
tristes mais en ayant vraiment une
réforme pénale centrale il ya un sur une
proposition que nous avons sur la table
on en a fait d'ailleurs tout au long de
ce mandat aussi bien au sénat d'ailleurs
qu'à l'assemblée nationale mais qui sont
malheureusement restées lettre morte on
va parler de roubaix puisque ophélie
meunier un habitant de la ville sont
menacés de mort placé sous protection
policière après la diffusion d'un
reportage de m6 sur l'islamisme radical
dans la ville de roubaix qu'est ce que
ça dit de l'état d'assiette et française
d'abord moi je peux affirmer tout mon
soutien ophélie meunier et toutes celles
et tous ceux qui ont réalisé ce
reportage
et rappeler que nous devons lutter de
manière implacable contre l'islamisme
radical au groupe l'est républicain nous
avons présenté des propositions fortes
pendant le débat sur la loi séparatisme
avec des mesures très concrètes
ça dit quoi ça dit que dans un certain
nombre de quartiers dans un certain
nombre de territoires sont devenus des
zones de non droit où ce sont les caïds
et ce sont les islamistes qui domine et
qu'il faut une lutte sans merci contre
l'islamisme radical est actuellement
mais elle commence mais il ya tellement
eu de retard dans là où ça il faut qu'on
ait les moyens de pouvoir fermer des
écoles coraniques il connaît pour des
moyens de pouvoir condamner un certain
nombre d'associations islamistes il faut
qu'on ait les moyens de lutter contre la
radicalisation en prison
ça donne un certain nombre d'outils mais
qui sont insuffisants on a un certain
nombre d'outils qu'on n'avait pas par le
passé il faut aller beaucoup plus loin
aujourd'hui pour lutter conditions
radicales mais je le dis aussi ne
tombons pas dans le piège parfois et
construit par les extrêmes qui est de
faire un égal entre musulmans et un
islamiste c'est pas la même chose et
autant il faut être implacables dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme islamique
autant il faut permettre aux musulmans
qui veulent s'intégrer dans la société
française de le faire c'est un combat
politique majeur et là il faut qu'on ait
des réponses y ont esquissé passaro b
est totalement inadmissible dans une
compromission total et ce qui se passe à
l'égard de philippe meunier et des
journalistes ont enquêté et qui ont fait
simplement leur travail d'enquêté
compromission du maire de la ville mais
non mais j'ai pas a jugé le maire c'est
pas du tout ça le jury s'est simplement
qu'aujourd'hui et une collision qui
s'est passé à roubaix qui n'est pas
acceptable parce que très clairement qu
est ce qu on doit constater aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on ne peut pas laisser d'être
morte à chaque fois qu'on fait une
enquête peut pas avoir derrière des
menaces de mort parce que ça c'est ça sa
di betta nos sociétés déradicalisation
qui est dans notre société aux normes ni
d'évoquer les zones de non droit alors
valérie pécresse utiliser un autre terme
si les zones de non france qu'est ce que
c'est original c'est intéressant qu'est
ce que qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous mettez derrière r ah
les zones de non france et les zones où
tout ça où les valeurs de la république
ne sont plus respectés c'est à dire le
vivre ensemble la fraternité et du coup
ça pénaliserait très large aussi oui
mais il faut que les gens comprennent ce
que c'est la réalité c'est que ces zones
dedans france est par exemple quand des
policiers ne peuvent plus rentrer dans
un quartier parce que ce sont les caïds
qui domine ce quartier moi je pense aux
habitants de ces quartiers qui sont les
premières victimes
en réalité que c'est ce sont les
premières victimes parce que il y habite
au quotidien et veulent qu'on leur
sortie de cet enfer de la drogue de cet
enfer de l'islamisme radical et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut pas faire d'amalgamé
parce que il faut aider ces gens là dans
né dans les quartiers qui sont les
premières victimes donc oui il ya des
zones de non france aujourd'hui et ces
zones de non france et une faillite de
l'état de droit il faut apporter une
réponse beaucoup plus fort de l'état
doit on va parler du pouvoir d'achat
préoccupation numéro 1 évidemment des
français y à de nouvelles hausses de
prix aujourd'hui et valérie pécresse
elle avait fait une des mesures phares
de sa campagne c'est la hausse de 10%
des salaires sur tout le quinquennat
alors là elle revient pas en arrière
elle a dit que non que qu'elle explique
sa mesure est permanent de 3% de baisse
des cotisations retraite dès l'été sur
le salaire brut une conférence des
salaires et elle dit qu'elle veut
convaincre le patronat comment ça
comment ça se passe si le patronat
refuse d'augmenter elle a d'abord c'est
pas un retour en arrière c'est pas un
retrouve un rétropédalage c'est
simplement une précision de la mise en
oeuvre de la mesure dire que valérie
pécresse dit elle veut avoir une
augmentation de 10% du salaire net elle
a raison ou défendant cette mesure qui
est un choc de pouvoir d'achat et c'est
la seule aujourd'hui à mettre une mesure
aussi forte en faveur des travailleurs
en faveur des salariés ceux qui se
lèvent tôt qui paie toujours tout qui
n'ont jamais droit à rien donc ça sera
la mettre en oeuvre oui ça maintenant la
création en deux temps c'est-à-dire
d'abord un premier temps nous l'avait
dit sur une augmentation de 3% avec la
suppression des cotisations patronales
et puis ensuite avec effectivement cette
conférence des salaires mais la
conférence des salaires c'est quoi tout
le monde ya intérêt aujourd'hui il faut
bien savoir que vous l'avez vu le
chômage recule en france dans certains
départements le mien par exemple un
département de l'ain nous n'avons pu en
prendre le chômage comme un problème
d'emploi et l'attractivité de l'emploi
et donc ça veut dire quoi se dire que
les patrons eux mêmes ont intérêt à
augmenter leurs salaires pourquoi parce
que si nous le montrent pas leurs
salaires aujourd'hui salaires de ceux
qui travaillent la réalité c'est que
l'intérêt à la reprise un travail ne
sera pas assez fort et donc ils auront
des problèmes pour recruter et pour
avoir la main d'oeuvre donc les salaires
il commence déjà à être valorisés dans
certains secteurs dans certains endroits
je vous rappelle que dans la
restauration ne trouve plus personne
dans le bâtiment aussi c'est ça la
réalité donc ce qu'elle dit valérie
pécresse s'est pas du tout un
renoncement c'est de dire je mettrai
tous les partenaires autour de la table
là où certains veulent par la loi elle
va faire une conférence sur les salaires
avec un objectif clair c'est celui des
10% soit si le patronat dit non parce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle a pas un peu cédé
au nom non n 3 mais en fait elle rend
dans une logique de négociation de
dialogue social qui est très important
puisque ce dialogue social il a manqué
pendant des années des années maintenant
si ce dialogue social échoue bas note la
majorité parlementaire futur prendra ses
responsabilités alors l ai dit que c'est
l'état qui prendra le relais ce jeu mais
le patronat l'état et l'autre partie il
y aura moins de baisses d'impôts de
produits pour les entrevues jeunesse que
du coup on n'est pas en train de faire
un chèque aux salariés avec l'argent du
contribuable ont pas du tout c'est de
dire c'est de faire du gagnant gagnant
se dire aux entreprises nous on est prêt
à vous renforcez votre compétitivité on
est prêt à continuer à baisser les
impôts production mais la contrepartie
de ça c'est que derrière vous pouvez
augmenter les inverse pourquoi parce que
des travailleurs pauvres ses travers qui
ne se réalisent pas dans leur travail et
donc leur productivité est moins forte
et parce que quand vous avez un écart
qui est insuffisant entre les revenus du
travail de revenus de l'assistance
qu'est-ce qui se passe eh bien vous avez
des personnes qui font le choix de faire
l'intérim de faire des cdd plutôt de cdi
et la fin des fins nous a des preuves de
recrutement donc moi je pense cette
conférence des salaires elle sera
gagnante gagnante il faut la faire je
préfère qu'on le fasse par le dialogue
social plutôt que l'imposé par la
contrainte et mais il aboutira dialogue
vous avez des éléments qui vous laissent
penser que le médecin comprends bien
votre louise couvrez-vous très
clairement ce jeu des échanges réguliers
avec des chefs d'entreprise par
département de fiel de france je peux
vous dire que chef d'entreprise sont
prêts à cela à une condition c'est qu'on
leur redonne de la compétitivité si on
leur donne d'un côté de la baisse des
charges de la baisse des impôts de
production et combien de temps augmenter
les salaires ils sont quel est le
problème en france c'est qu'il ya trop
d'écart entre le brut et le net et que
cet écart important entre le brut et net
fait qu'aujourd'hui et bien forcément ça
coûte trop cher pour les battre donc oui
il ya une prise de conscience car elle
est encore une fois si jamais ça échoue
eh bien l'état et la majorité
parlementaire prendre leurs
responsabilités et on n'a rien exclu de
voter une loi derrière on va parler des
victoire de la fracture territoriale de
la france rurale ce sont des thèmes que
vous portez aux républicains on veut
vous faire réagir à cette proposition
d'eric zemmour qu'elle a lancée il ya
quelques jours il propose une bourse de
naissance de 10000 euros pour un enfant
qui est né en zone rurale qu'est ce que
vous en pensez je trouve ça stigmatisant
et démagogique la réalité c'est quoi ça
veut dire quoi c'est à dire qu'en gros
vous vous êtes né dans une zone rurale
on vous donne dix mille euros mais ça
veut dire qu'on considère que tous ceux
qui sont nés en zone rurale son port et
sa consigne on considère aussi que tous
ceux qui sont nés dans des villes ou en
zones urbaines sont riches excusez moi
de vous dire même à paris a pas que des
gens qui sont riches et que c'est une
vision totalement fausses démagogiques
et anachronique de la société française
qui vise qu'une seule chose fracture est
toujours et encore on a bien compris
quelle était la stratégie l'extrême
droite fracturée toujours encore donc ça
ce sont des fausses bonnes solutions
personne n'y croit à la vérité moi je
vis dans un milieu rural où c'est dans
le territoire du haut bugey tout le
monde m'a dit mais c'est une vaste
blague sais tu vois la personne n'y
croit ses doigts c'est la campagne comme
on aime pas c'est à dire d'appel du truc
à deux balles et sur le montant lui-même
10000 euros comme ça et c'est quoi ça
15000 et puissant mine aussi fâché c'est
ce que vous proposez
on joue pour l'auto on est dans une
campagne présidentielle et où ça y est
la politique c'est sérieux et c'est
aussi pour ça que je me suis engagé aux
côtés de valérie pécresse c'est que
toutes ces propositions sérieuses à sion
crédibilisation financer c'est tellement
facile de raconter n'importe quoi
toujours alors c'est bien d'avoir des
propositions sérieuses on fera encore
faut-il pouvoir les exposer et en
débattre là on sentait que n'y aura pas
de débat avant le premier tour du côté
du président de la république sortant
quand il décidera de d'annoncer sa
candidature marine le pen enchaîne le
pas en disant qu'elle veut pas débattre
non plus
comment si les messieurs n'ont même pas
conscience par dossier manomètres on y
voit pas comment comment on fait dans
ces conditions pour pouvoir confronter
les a cédées avant de prendre jusqu'à 30
points sur la france cheval c'est que
pour moi il ya deux ans je sais la santé
et l'école et sur la santé l'école nous
avons des propositions très concrètes
qui ont été portées sur la question du
débat - jeu je comprends pas quand on
est candidat à l'élection présidentielle
même quand on est là statut de président
sortant on se doit des pâtes est ce que
les présidents de région sortants ont
refusé le débat dans la campagne
régionale ils ont débattu laurent
wauquiez valérie pécresse xavier
bertrand ils ont fait des débats de
premier tour avec l'ensemble des
candidats et ils étaient prises andré en
sortant donc je vois pas en quoi ce
statut de président sortant empêcherait
toute forme de débat à moins que on
craignent le débat politique voilà mais
moi je considère que pour la bonne pour
les françaises et les français c'est
important qu'il ya un échange en débat
et ce débat doit avoir lieu avant le 3
comment vous comprenez cette stratégie
là en fait assez une stratégie
d'évitement quand on veut faire campagne
on veut faire campagne sans faire
campagne on veut profiter du statut de
président pour ne pas montrer qu'on est
candidat voilà c'est un mélange des
genres mais moi j'espère que ça que les
choses évolueront pour le débat
démocratique français et puis surtout
que les français il faut qu'il ait une
pression populaire et une pression
médiatique pour que ce débat il est lieu
encore une fois il a eu lieu pour les
présidents de région sortants je vois
pas pourquoi il devrait pas lui présent
la réplique sur ton juste là dessus sur
le fait qu emmanuel un conte frais
campagne c'est ce que vous dites sans
être candidat déclaré christian jacob
dans le figaro il ya quelques jours il
disait qu'on n'est pas loin du
détournement de fonds publics vous irait
jusqu'à la route et christian jacob il
l'a dit il est président du parti il a
saisi je crois commission des comptes de
campagne pour que les choses soient
clarifiées
il ya un besoin de clarification qui est
nécessaire qui est indispensable voilà
donc donc il faut vous savez il faut
faire attention à une chose c'est que
tout le monde sur un pied d'égalité moi
j'ai noté aussi que dernièrement il ya
un décret qui est sorti par le premier
ministre un décret qui interdit à tous
les journalistes de pouvoir accompagner
une équipe de candidats dans les
bâtiments publics très concrètement dans
un hôpital dans dans un ehpad voilà ça
ça pose quand même des difficultés quand
même la campagne présidentielle ce peut
être une idée pas à une campagne low
cost au rabé il faut qu'ils aient un
vrai débat politique alors à propos de
campagne le vrai débat politique ou est
ce qu est ce que valérie pécresse on est
de la sienne de campagne à écouter le
parcours au la france elle était chez
moi à oyonnax la semaine dernière sur
les thématiques de santé elle sera
encore en déplacement cette semaine
c'est quoi c'est est ce que ça ne signe
pas un peu quand même une percée après
le congrès d alerte c'est logique c'est
toujours logique vous avez une percée
après les primaires la différence est
contrairement à monsieur hamon elle
s'est pas effondré et s'est stabilisée
et la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que les
français ils ont compris quoi ils ont
compris que c'est la seule qui pouvait
battre emmanuel macron et que monsieur
et madame le pen sur les deux meilleures
assurances vie pour la réélection de
mâcon ils ont compris quoi ils ont
compris que c'est la seule fois on
pouvait mettre une femme à la tête de
l'elysée ils ont ils sont en train de la
découvrir la vérité c'est qu'il ya elle
est moins connu certainement parce que
collet parce qu'il y en a ça fait 2-2
campagne trois campagnes quatre
campagnes qui font elles c'est la
première campagne présidentielle greffet
moi ce que je note c'est qu'à chaque
puce et français la déco et plus ils
adhèrent pas simplement à son projet
politique mais il adhère aussi à la
femme qu'elle est et qu'elle incarne
cire de la modernité de l'autorité de la
liberté qui veut mettre le travail en
priorité donc je pense que plus on va
rentrer dans la campagne et plus elle va
monter parce que les français vont la
découvrir
on est en pleine période des ralliements
là en ce moment donc vous n'avez vous ne
redoutez pas qui est incertaine au
départ des républicains vers le camp
vers le camp d'en face et inversement
est ce que vous attendez des arrivées
chez vous par exemple quand edouard
philippe live vos tweets à la gloire de
valérie pécresse vous pensez vous prenez
qui vous pensez qu'il va la vie va me
revient d'abord beaucoup amusé ce laïc
ceci soit il ya de la condescendance
soyez du jeu trouble soient ya les deux
ludique ce d'ironie oui la vérité c'est
qu'il ya un peu de condescendance à
l'égard de valérie pécresse pense que
mon réflexe même tweets pour d'autres
peut-être que réparer agi ainsi mais il
ya peut-être aussi un jeu trouble et un
message envoyé aussi à emmanuel macron
c'est quoi c'est à dire qu'il a il joue
sur les deux tableaux pour aide au
séjour un peu le schéma permet un petit
coup de pression politique avec l'ironie
on fait parfois passer beaucoup de
messages politiques
[Musique]